all right i see snow up in the mountains
too and boy do we need it now
as monica says this weather is going to
be a little dicey as far as navigating
through it today rain and mountain snow
look for winter weather driving
conditions we had some real gusty winds
overnight
but a lot of those have calmed down
temperatures in the 40s let's talk about
the mountains because
that's where it's going to be i think
the trickiest the slipperiest and the
if you don't need to be up in the
mountains today i would just avoid it
now we're looking for some great snow
totals
we're keeping our fingers crossed that
we might get a foot maybe even a foot
and a half of snow with this winter
storm
by midday tomorrow highs in the 20s will
be dropping into the teens through the
day
and snow levels will be dropping they've
been down generally to about 3000 feet
so far that's down to red rock and a
little bit lower
already here's the storm it still has to
slip into southern california
and then it's going to take a turn to
the east and head our way through
southern nevada over into arizona
so while we've seen some overnight rain
minimal amounts
trace officially less than five
hundredths of an inch up into the moapa
valley
and good snow so far but it's kind of
taken a break
there's more down here if you look down
towards barstow it's all going to start
coming up i-15
i think after 8 o'clock we're going to
start seeing more rain and snow
taking shape across the valley so maybe
towards the end of the morning commute
we've got chad graves our live
photographer he's out on the roads this
morning out on 2 15
and he's been looking for kind of that
mix of maybe a little rain
with some snowflakes and so far the
roads have been pretty good
but there have been some wet spots and
just know that when we get more of that
winter weather through the day
low visibility slippery roads give
yourself plenty of room between you and
the cars around you
and please slow down no cruise control
either if there's snow on the roads and
there could be snow
on valley roads as we've got a winter
weather advisory issued
for valley locations the lower
elevations we could get snow down to
2000 feet
or lower later today into tonight we
could put a
we could get an inch of snow on the
strip we could get an inch or two up in
summerlin
maybe more red rocks looking for two to
eight inches of snow
remember our last really good snowfall
was february of 2019
so folks kind of forget what's it like
to drive on snow
oh yeah and when you're out there you'll
remember fast
47 for the high today and we'll be
looking for that chance of rain off and
on likely and again i think it will pick
up a little bit more after 8 a.m this
morning
and then into tonight and early tomorrow
that chance of snow
even into the valley and lower
elevations we get a break midweek from
the storms
50 degrees and cloudy and then a slight
chance of rain again late thursday with
rain likely with a second storm this
week
into friday and then seems like a fairly
nice weekend
cool though mid 50s sunshine and clouds